thank you for coming here thank you
Maggie for inviting us I'm glad you are
interested in the story of devrel at
snowflake
there are other companies they have
always awesome Deborah teams but this is
our story so we are happy to share it we
thought of this presentation with Daniel
as something that we would show a new
teammate someone that we are recruiting
anyone that's interested in seeing how
we approach devrel what we have done so
far we uh we would love to have your
questions
um this is our story anything before I
begin Daniel yeah I think that's it yeah
that's it so let's get started good
morning
yes people strictly mean from the
keynote so uh I'm sure this is a data
conference I'm sure most of you are
familiar with snowflake yes this is like
the place to be familiar with Snowflake
and I love this picture I took the
screenshot a couple months ago but it
shows how snowflake has risen from out
of nowhere like it didn't exist 12 years
ago to now being almost a top 10
database of all databases so it's really
fun to see the story and how we
arrived here
um
I don't know if people know me but
this is me right now on stack overflow
on snowflake I'm number three I'm a
developer advocate for snowflake I've
been here for the last two and a half
years now
but part of what's really interesting
here is to that being number three on
the top
for stack Overflow of all time it's hard
I'm surrounded by great users I'm
surrounded by other teammates employees
we are all we all love answering
questions and before joining us
snowflake uh I was at Google for eight
years for 10 years I was a developer
advocate for bigquery for eight so there
I'm number two and there I'm going to be
number two for a long time so
anyways
um this is how snowflake has risen
maybe we will see snowflake asset in the
top 10 very soon I joined you can guess
where I joined in 2020 uh I don't know
if it's related that it went up that
high or if it was the IPO but it was the
perfect time to start and then you'll
start at about the same time a couple
months before me yep
um and a quick story of snowflake it was
founded in 2012
um in 2017 the community team started uh
2019 Graziano joined the first
evangelist for the snowflake but back in
2020 uh snowflake didn't have a
developer relations team snowflake
didn't have developer Advocates which is
also a pretty interesting thing to see
because
developer relations is so important for
so many companies here and snowflake was
able to succeed without a formal
developer relations team but in 2020 we
were invited to join I remember seeing
an ad like this this is a more recent
one but I remember in the middle of 2020
we were all at home somewhere that's not
like invited me to see this and the ad
said something like
we are looking for our first developer
Advocate we are looking for someone to
Define what devrel is going to be to set
our metrics to organize our team and I
saw that and I was like that's not me
I'm not interested in creating plans I'm
not interested in defining strategies I
I just want to do the job I want to be
out there I want to be a developer
Advocate having fun but Daniel saw the
same ad and Daniel said that's it
exactly and so for the next part of the
story then you'll please thank you
Felipe awesome so
before I get started I want to see quick
show of hands who here
considers themselves working in devrel
either a developer Advocate evangelist
uh Community manager something to do
with devrel
awesome a quick show of hands who here
uh is you know considers themselves a
data scientist
uh who considers themselves a app
developer
awesome data engineer
beautiful so
the devrel function at snowflake covers
really those three core personas we call
them builders
that is app Dev data Engineers data
scientists and that that really the
definition the broader definition of a
builder for us
is really any technical practitioner
that's building something in Snowflake
and so when I joined snowflake
this devrel function simply did not
exist like Felipe said
there was no Mission there was no idea
on how to you know build up this
adoption by builders
all all the all the business knew was
like Hey Builders use our product
we need some we need a team that can
that can really focus on that
um and build a Bottoms Up adoption so
product LED or community-led growth
to expand our already top-down sales and
marketing approach that snowflake had
and so
with that in mind
we've put together our mission statement
uh objectives and kpis these are these
are North Star so kind of the the
defining function across all of the
different programs and initiatives that
we as a team do and that is pretty
simple make snowflake the data platform
of Choice by developers or in this case
builders
and that is and how do we do that
through objectives well it's building
awareness growing share of voice across
different communities
um and at the end of the day increasing
consumption snowflake is a
consumption-based product
we want to increase consumption uh but
and we see developers as a core element
of building and growing consumption of
snowflake
and how do we actually measure that so
it's total number of developers on a
monthly basis we can see that you know
based on trial signups for example
um and we can see that also by
communities both ones that we own
ourselves so community.snowflake.com but
as well as third party communities
Reddit stack Overflow
um medium you name it we can see how how
those online communities are growing
um we can measure uh you know sentiment
on those we can see uh you know and tie
in the different questions that are
happening there
um and at the end of the day right we
want to be able to influence you know
have the community influence their their
own decision makers
um and these capacity deals again going
to towards consumption of snowflake so
we as a team come to this with a few
assumptions both on our product and what
we think will be successful as a product
um and also for customers what these
some assumptions that we have for our
customers so that is that Engineers are
absolutely critical
and have a uniquely different set of
needs than business users
that those needs include you know
actually developing uh you know things
on snowflake using snowflake with other
tools
um yeah and so
for example
um you know the
the amount of
escalation when snowflake goes down for
a developer is much higher than if it's
you know you can't access a dashboard
for for some time but you but for a
developer it could mean that your entire
app stops working
and so
um and we also see that developers
influence these deals at snowflake we
call them internal Champions these are
folks that love and use snowflake
already
um and are our key element of growth
within our customers so different teams
within our customers and and helping to
promote snowflake within their own
company
we also want to build a high quality
pipeline uh that is that our sales and
rest of our marketing function can use
right so
um at the end of the day
our goal is to spread adoption of
snowflake
um and how do we do that
well we have a mental model on how we
kind of crystallize
down these assumptions about our product
and about our customers
um joining that with
the mission statement and kpis into
three core buckets of deliverables for
for devrel snowflake that is content
product and community
so content is all about
whether about creating sample code blog
posts videos you name it both
educational content so how do you
actually use snowflake to build the
solutions that you need but also
awareness content are you even aware
that you can do X Y and Z with snowflake
um
and so that is a very core element today
and depending on where you are the the
life cycle of your product you as a team
will spend more or less time on one of
these buckets
when we look at product bucket the
product bucket for snowflake in devrel
really spans two ends of the product
life cycle that is the very beginning
helping to influence product roadmap
which features get developed
specifically for developers and builders
in this case
um and how do we do that well we we
literally in the room helping to define
the functional spec of different
features
um and then on the other end of that
feature life cycle is when we go and
launch a new feature so really the go to
market function so do we have that right
content in place when the feature
launches and are we engaging the
community in the right way
and so that brings me to the third
bucket community community is absolutely
critical for any devrel team
in particular for snowflake there's a
few
Key Programs across community that we
have today I mentioned prior you know we
have our community platforms so
community.s snowflake.com where
snowflake users and and Builders can go
on ask questions interact with other
builders on on snowflake
but we also by Design engage developers
and Builders where they are Elsewhere on
the internet
you go to medium go to Reddit
Etc so we as a as part of our mission
and part of our design is is to engage
developers everywhere
um and uh so a couple Key Programs there
is
all of those Community platforms but two
our ambassador program at snowflake we
call it data superheroes what are they
these are snowflake Super users that uh
they themselves use snowflake in and out
all the time in their in their job and
their function and they love snowflake
what are some benefits of being one of a
data a data Superior for snowflake well
one it's it's two ways one we help
promote them in the in the industry but
two we also love to get feedback from
them
on private preview beta you know NDA
level feedback on snowflake as a product
um and so there's that goes back to the
product bucket as well so these three my
point being is that these three buckets
of tangible deliverables that we as a
team execute on
um are very uh collaborative and
cross-functional so the content goes
towards both the launch of new features
awareness education
and so on so let's look at
some of the key devrel programs that we
at snowflake have today
so at snowflake we have a few very key
ones one is quick starts quick starts
dot snowflake.com this is a tutorial
platform
with end-to-end tutorial content
complete with all of the source code
instructions images videos
so that
by the end of completing that tutorial
you have something running inside of
your own snowflake instance
and that covers both Solutions so you
know how to build a movie recommendation
engine on snowflake you can go watch
that and learn how to do that today at
quickstarts.noflick.com
we also have uh so how do we categorize
different quick starts we have getting
started
so this is by Persona so whether that be
getting started by if you're a developer
right here's the core set of features
for that app developers would most
likely want to do and keep that short
and sweet same thing with data Engineers
here's here's the core set of features
that snowflake provides out of the box
if you're a data engineer and you're and
doing that same thing with data science
the other is getting started by feature
so if you just want to learn about hey I
want to learn how to use time travel
with snowflake I want to learn how to
just use snowpark with snowflake I'm
going to learn how to use the python
connector you can get started just laser
in on a specific feature
we also have Solutions I mentioned you
know build a movie recommendation engine
um you know hey I want to ingest all the
Twitter all the tweets
um in a fire hose fashion and do live
sentiment analysis on those tweets for
specific keywords absolutely we have a
quick start to show you exactly how to
do that
um
the other the last is partner
Integrations
snowflake at its core is loves partners
and we as a go to market function are
very much partner first almost all the
things that we do since we're an
underlying platform needs Partners to
complete the rest of that solution and
so you'll see over and over again many
many partner oriented quick starts how
to use x with snowflake how to set this
up in your snowflake environment and set
it up in in whatever partner uh platform
or application that they may have
so the next program here at snowflake
live in GitHub this is critical for
Builders of all kinds this is where we
host our open source projects sample
code tools that you may use
and how do we categorize the and think
about open source that's snowflake this
is a big one because uh
we have the sample code that that is on
quick starts but we also want to help
promote and build a robust open source
community of tools
uh that we know our customers use
a great example of that is Django for
python so we have open source Django
connector for python that you can go and
leverage today same thing with terraform
a great example of this and I'll touch
on this further is you know the
terraform provider and how we've worked
with uh the Chan Zuckerberg Initiative
for example to adopt the open source
provide terraform provider that they
developed into
um into Snowflake and now we help to
manage and maintain that
um videos is a big one uh videos is
probably one of the fastest growing
mediums for Content consumption uh not
just among developers but probably just
in general
um and so we see that as a core element
of how we go about building uh the Mind
share uh and awareness for snowflake
other another one is events events for
snowflake like this one
um is a key element as well for us so we
want to uh leverage events like this
where we can engage one-on-one with the
community in this fashion do do live q
and A's uh workshops
um really get Hands-On in person for
snowflake uh and Builders of snowflake
um which ties into the workshop's last
one so the workshops both are in person
at events like this but also online
virtual uh we have what are called
virtual Hands-On Labs you can go and
sign up we have them every single week
what are those and how does it tie into
the rest of the programs well every
single Hands-On lab or Workshop is
simply a quick start that is
instructor-led and that is by Design we
want to keep as much on virtually all of
our content ungated
that's for several reasons one
uh we you know having it ungated
promotes organic search and growth so
when you search for uh Twitter and
snowflake hey our quick start is
probably on the front page
um and uh you know and and so building
this organic growth is a key element of
growing these programs so
um you know we see some of these we have
like our terraform snowflake uh guide
here on on quick starts is is the top
one today if you if you Google search
terraform and snowflake you will get our
Quick Start
um and uh for example the DBT one top
partner guide uh you know for traffic if
you type in Snowflake DBT that will be
literally the number one result on on
Google search
when we look at snowflake Labs the
terraform adoption from czi so how did
this actually go about
um so we saw from our customers
increasing demand for a a CO
infrastructure as code solution
specifically terraform
and uh this was getting from coming from
our sales teams escalating it to product
escalating it to us saying hey you know
there's this open source project our
customers are are asking can snowflake
add to it because we're using it in
production we want snowflake to support
XYZ features in this terraform provider
um and it turns out also snowflake
ourselves used this provider to manage
our own snowflake instances
um and so ultimately that's that's how
we adopted it
um the same engineering team that uses
it internally at snowflake is the same
engineering team that is developing it
for our customers today
um and uh and so czi still today
contributes to this terraform provider
as well that is a key element of really
all of these open source projects that
we engage in is
just because we adopt it
that that by Design we don't want to uh
say no to external contributions like we
we want more external contributions so
um and so we want to deepen the presence
of Open Source and really build out this
robust ecosystem of Integrations open
source projects that you can use
snowflake with
so snow powered by Snowflake and video
interviews in general so
um video This goes back to kind of how
we leverage videos as a key element of
consumption for Builders
so this powered by series for example is
targeting developers Founders CTO so
kind of
the executive down to individual
developer on the technical side of of
business and really attacking it at two
angles right on showing why they built
their business an application on
snowflake so going deep into you know uh
both the business reasons hey they were
able to partner with snowflake do a
joint go to market but also go deep into
the features why did they choose
snowflake to build on were there
specific things that were were uh you
know deal breakers uh for other you know
for other platforms and why they chose
snowflake were their core
differentiators that snowflake provided
as to why they chose snowflake to build
end to end their application on top of
um and so you can Google this for
example today this is just one of many
video series that we have and the point
is we want to tackle really all of these
different areas across the board for uh
Builders of all kinds to answer their
questions so that if they Google search
it we want a quick start we want a video
we want a blog post we want all these
things from Snowflake essentially on the
front page
organic search is absolutely critical
so developer communities we see
continual growth of all of our external
communities medium Reddit stack Overflow
and you'll see here you know snowflake
is the fastest growing stack Overflow
um you know it's the blue line there
um and uh across across uh different
elements there
um same thing with the community at
snowflake.com continues to grow
significantly
um you know month over month
um where we are grabbing all sorts of of
users of snowflake
now from here I'll pass back to sleep
thank you yeah so that's how Daniel
spends his day
um I love that he's doing this like
planning all of this bringing people
together bringing teams together selling
this to marketing and how we should be
doing devrel uh setting up Partnerships
talking with people and instead I spend
my day out there I spend my day on the
DVD slag on stack overflow on Reddit and
is saying how these numbers increase and
increase and increase these are
screenshots from November October
um
when I joined 2020 we had less than 200
000 page views a quarter on stack
Overflow where over a million now uh on
Reddit we it was the snowflakes up
Reddit was almost dead but I adopted it
now we are on five right now we are
almost at six thousand uh on the DVD
flag I love seeing that the snowflake
channel is the largest one of all the
vendors Simon Reddit that engineering um
um when someone asked on this survey
what data Lake Warehouse do you use
snowflake is the most popular one and
for me this is extraordinary because
again I had a career in Data before
joining snowflake snowflake didn't exist
when I started this announced snowflake
is everywhere and I love it we still
have challenges like in this conference
everyone recognizes Snowflake and then
if I go uh to a devops conference most
people don't know it so that's part of
the talent we continue
um fighting with like how do we make
people that aware that snowflake exists
that they may love it and but yeah as
Daniel was saying we have all these
programs and we also have developer
Advocates on the ground being present
doing the job
I love this one that I an award that I
got from the DB from DVT where they
recognized the top
vendors Community Players in their space
and there was my name along with other
snowflakes and it's really cool to see
that recognition that being present
being there dedicating my time to
to
to be part of a community can be
recognized too and that's part of the
how we show our different Focus but
they're both welcome to Snowflake and
both are very important jobs this is
just to show you a little bit of how our
team looks this is back in 2020 we
joined but there was already a team
present Daniel was reporting to wakasu
what was waka's title at the time uh
director of uh developer marketing
developer marketing yes and we had Andy
and Elsa doing community and Kent was
our evangelist and we have our awesome
management at least that help me hire
Daniel and our CMO that Denise and they
are great great leaders to work with
part of the
uh
questions that we you always have for
devrelis where should Deborah sit
um in our case it's it's marketing other
companies products other companies it's
engineering
uh they all have Pro and cons but having
this leadership has been a really great
experience for us
um a little bit of sorry so snowflake
founded in 2012. I already went through
that but then after we joined we had the
snowflake APO
and then in 2021 after we joined
um
was put in charge of all things devil
and Community
um Dash joined in 2021 our developer
Advocate team and Gilberto just joined
us and I'm super happy to see him with a
snowflake t-shirt that he was worried
that he didn't have yesterday so looking
good uh now and I'm glad that the team
is growing so this is basically how our
team looks now what classes managers
Community devrel uh we have lace as a
manager for Community the community team
you can see how it has grown our
developer Advocates team has Run 2 we're
growing also our program management
management team program
Francisco is working all things open
source and getting us
um
how do we manage our open source
relationship with the communities within
snowflake our leadership continues there
and I also have the pictures of two of
our evangelists that are not part of
wakastim but they are our evangelists in
Europe and yes we all have this job of
being present being there
learning teaching learning listening Etc
yeah so as Felipe said you know you
different or different devrel teams are
part of different organizations
depending on the company that you see
so for the people that the uh quick show
of hands here for the people that are in
devrel in any function of devrel
um how many of you report into uh
engineering org
okay for those of you uh in devrel
reporting into a product team
marketing team
you see right here
be different you know pretty pretty good
mix of folks we're reporting into these
three marketing product engineering when
does it make sense for a
devrel team to report into each of these
well
it's going to be opinionated on based on
who you ask but the way I see it
is that uh
the depending on the product maturity
and the customers that you have so the
segments that you have
real really Define what where it makes
sense for your devrel team to sit
um where where your devrel team sits has
a very large influence on on what North
Star metrics you as a team have
um and uh and so
at snowflake we are part of the
marketing org
and uh you'll see that with snow with
devrel in general
right you have many times the devrel
team focuses on the long tail of
customers so the independent developers
uh startups things like that and so
depending on what your product is
will Define of how important is that
segment to the overall business success
and
um and also the maturity of where your
product is do you have the Mind share
already within the industry or do you
need to build that mind share and focus
more on content across these different
channels to build mind share
um and as your and for your product
roadmap are you expanding into different
areas that need to build and and grow
your mind share in those areas and so
um no matter what a devrel a good devrel
team
will have the skill set necessary to fit
in all three of these that's the key
element here that's the that's kind of
the key takeaway is that as a devrel
team
you will be targeting all three of these
metrics and and the question is for the
business which ones should you be
focusing on
um and spending you know a lot of time
on uh but you still need to have the
background and expertise
for uh for across all three
so
uh what's next for devrel at snowflake
so much uh you can do it let's do it
together yeah so we can set up get ready
for the questions we'll have questions
so what's next
level is growing yeah so devrel is
growing so this is a big piece um you
know this is uh in part recruitment so
if you are interested in joining
snowflake let me know
um and we are hiring globally
um and uh so we keep evolving
um and uh Felipe you want to talk more
about that oh for sure like before I
join snowflake used to be the best data
warehouse that's how it was solved then
snowflake kept growing as a product uh
the reach of what it can do and I will
message in change to snowflake is the
cloud data platform
and then when I joined in 2020 when we
joined we were snowflake is the data
Cloud as snowflake became a place to
share data to move data between
companies without having to physically
move it and share and have everything
governed and now what are those three
thoughts for
um you know snowflake 3.0
the uh so as snowflake continues to grow
uh snowflake is becoming a general
developer platform for all things data
and that really kind of ties into the
idea of the data cloud and expanding on
that Vision so
um as a builder uh I encourage you to
check out developers.snowflake.com
and uh and learn more about how
snowflake can uh can help you yep and we
listed here some of the areas where
snowflake is growing to with snow park
with its abilities to do ml with Apache
Iceberg with uni store stream lead
we are adopting now the Django connector
this is ways of building apps however
we're going tackling streaming how are
we tackling up the whole picture having
90 Labs connected apps Etc there's so
much to do so many areas to focus if you
want to join snowflake
and but by the by the way we are not on
this alone we told the story of
developer relations as seen from Aston
anyone else on our team has a pretty
interesting story and I want to call out
our sales Engineers industry Solutions
our field ctOS partners team the
engineers that are out there the ux
people that love getting your feedback
field marketing that's that's events
everywhere
documentations PMS it's just an
incredible team to be part of and they
are all they all want to have more
developers to listen to their feedback
and create a great product
fantastic and so with this again thank
you everybody for joining us here today
[Music]